this week on brian ross investigates
the other tape a new york police
department training video
that warned of the dangers of the knee
to neck restraint technique
persons on their stomachs can't breathe
with pressure applied to their backs
it really had a simple message that as
soon as a prone suspect
is handcuffed get him off this shot but
that did not happen in the george floyd
case
even though that nypd tape was part of
the training
for minneapolis police officers for the
last seven years
with the junior officers in the floyd
case asking whether
he should be put on his side
and officer shovin who was a training
officer and senior officer of theirs
plus a nationwide series of hate crimes
aimed
at asian americans leading president
biden
to issue a stern warning it's wrong
it's un-american and it must stop
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
as chosen by the editors of mediaite see
if you agree
with their selections
that's not the question from the law and
crime
trial network this is brian ross
investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our
viewers on facebook live i'm brian ross
joined tonight as always by my colleague
rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with new information
in the case of george floyd
as the city of minneapolis has now
agreed to pay george floyd's family some
27 million dollars to settle a wrongful
death suit
it's the biggest such settlement
involving a police brutality case ever
but as we're learning it's hardly the
only one that has taken place rhonda
that's right it turns out there have
been hundreds over a hundred
deaths and tens of millions of dollars
paid out in settlements around the
country
with because of the use of these prone
restraints
by police
persons on their stomachs can't breathe
with pressure applied to their backs
as soon as suspects are handcuffed get
them off their stomachs
this video was produced by the new york
city police department in 2003
showing the dangers of the knee-to-neck
restraint
technique the video was widely
circulated to police departments around
the country
including to minneapolis it really had a
simple message
that as soon as a prone suspect is
handcuffed
get him off his shoulder and yet it was
still being used in minneapolis by
derrick shuttle it was still being used
in minneapolis
it's still being used in cities
around the country and you know using
prone restraint
to uh take custody if someone happens
every single day
reporter aj lego of minneapolis tv
station
care 11 found the technique has left a
long trail of deaths
we know of at least 107 deaths that
followed prone restraint since 2010.
there are likely many more he
was on the ground for too
long with his hand handcuffed with his
hands behind his back with
too many police officers on top of him
we found families
impacted by loss in places like
louisiana
texas north carolina california
and arizona and the fact that it
continues to happen
today is why i'm talking to you now in a
country nearly
two-thirds white more than two-thirds of
the deaths we found
involve people who were not and the
kir-11 report found that more than half
the deaths
involve people battling mental illness
david smith committed
no crime but he battled mental illness
and his behavior at the downtown ymca in
raised red flags for staff and the
police were called
it escalated to a struggle ending with
officers kneeling on david's back for
about
four minutes his autopsy shows he died
due to mechanical asphyxia caused by
prone restraint
david's family thought police would
learn from his death
when my brother died and we fought and
fought to show how dangerous this
position was
after david smith died his family
filed a lawsuit um they sued
and in 2013 minneapolis paid out one of
the biggest police misconduct lawsuit
settlements
at the time in the city's history and
as part of that settlement the city of
minneapolis agreed
to require its sworn police officers
every one of them
to undergo training on positional
asphyxia
and it turned out part of the training
was playing that nypd
video showing the dangers of the
technique and the importance
of getting the suspect on his side they
were going to be playing
a video at roll calls so that each
officer saw it and
that is that new york city training
video
every officer had to see that actually
when george floyd died and you see the
cell phone video that's gone around the
world
you see some of them you can hear some
of the younger officers that have only
been on the job
asking hey should we get him on his side
hey should we roll him on his side
and officer shoven who was a training
officer and
senior officer there says no
so naturally when george floyd died
we began asking that question what
happened to that
promised training from the david smith
case and
we got a lot of run around initially but
eventually
the minneapolis police chief issued a
really
incredible statement that claimed that
mpd
fulfilled the training requirement it
was given to all officers and he said
quote i can confirm that officer shovin
and tao had this training what i
observed
and i want to be very just mindful that
obviously this
case is under investigation but what i
observed
uh was not training that i ever
participated in and that's
no small point it's likely going to be a
key piece of evidence
in the officer's murder trial that they
had been trained
to get off the back of someone after
they had them
in custody we're joined now by chuck
wexler he's the executive director
of the police executive research firm
and chuck thanks for being here tonight
let me ask you police chiefs around the
country
must be watching what's going on in
minneapolis what are they doing about it
what are they thinking about it
well i think it's a defining moment for
policing in general
um this is one of those situations where
you hope that the jurors will see what
they see and that is
very bad police behavior criminal
behavior
uh but it's you know this sense of being
out of control this is the american
system you have
jurors there that will hear the evidence
but
every police chief that i know of that
have seen that video
just is appalled and we just hope that
um that justice will prevail because
that does not represent
what good policing is it it is it is
just the opposite
and um and and it will have
ramifications across the country and
around the world that verdict uh
will uh will have a significant impact
brian you remember the rodney king
situation 30 years ago
and how how significant that was
we just hope in this case people will
see it and make their own judgment but i
can tell you that there's not a police
chief that i know of
that watched that video and wasn't
completely
sick to their stomach
it was not the first time that happened
in minneapolis supposedly there was a
whole
series of training videos shown to
police at at roll calls
is this a failure of discipline a
failure of training
uh well i think it's it's it's it's bad
policing i mean there's there's nothing
there's no training that i know of that
would have a
police officer be on someone's neck for
nine minutes when they're asking
when they say they can't breathe even
the officers
who were there knew enough to say
shouldn't we roll him over on his side
uh or could there be this be excited
delirium
uh but uh no i it's it's a failure
on a number of different fronts but um
but most of all on the human front
no human being can watch that video and
not just be sick to their stomach
and so what are police chiefs going to
do to get past this black eye
on policing in general
well i think you know i think it's uh
it's not just
this case but it's just taking a hard
look at training on supervision on
hiring uh we really we really need to
fundamentally change
uh training on use of force
it hasn't really changed in a number of
years
and uh we are in the middle of that
right now but this case is probably
symbolic of of what went wrong and
what's wrong but
you know that training that that officer
received
uh i don't know of any other department
that that has that training
but it's bigger than just that i mean it
can't be simply that particular incident
there's a whole bunch of other things
that have happened that we've learned
you know the interesting thing about
body worn video
today is what police departments do when
something happens in some place like
whether it's kenosha or rochester or uh
minneapolis is they'll take those videos
and they'll say what would we have done
in our city if this had happened
a lot of our thinking should be how do
we prevent
excessive force how do we de-escalate
how do we communicate with people
talk to people and this notion of
proportionality
you know if it's an active shooter the
police have to win
right but there are other situations
when someone's in crisis
uh winning at all costs doesn't make any
sense particularly when you go to
someone's house and someone says their
kid is out of control
you know we got to teach police how to
deal with those situations in such a way
that everybody goes home safe at night
all right chuck wexler executive
director of the police executive
research forum
thank you so much for being with us
tonight
thanks brian
coming up the spike in violent attacks
against asian americans
what's behind it you're watching brian
ross investigates on the long crime
trial network
even as all eyes are focused on the case
of george floyd and police misconduct in
minneapolis
there's another troubling issue that's
getting some well-deserved attention
all the way to the white house a spike
in
violent attacks against asian americans
across the country
an uptick in recent weeks in violent
attacks
against asian americans this
surveillance video capturing an alleged
assailant
in california violently shoving an 84
year old thai
american man to the ground he died of
his injuries days later
this surveillance footage shows a 71
year old asian grandmother violently
shoved to the ground
her purse stolen 52 year old woman
being pushed to the ground on roosevelt
avenue in flushing queens tuesday
a 91 year old man pushed in oakland's
chinatown
a 36-year-old victim who is
asian-american walking when his attacker
runs up behind
and stabs him vicious hate crimes
against asian americans
who've been attacked harassed blamed and
scapegoated
at this very moment so many of them
are fellow americans they're on the
front lines of this pandemic trying to
save lives
and still still they're forced to live
in fear
for their lives just walking down
streets in america
it's wrong it's un-american and it
must stop
we're joined now by john yang of the
group asian americans
advancing justice and mr yang thank you
for being here tonight
were you heartened to see president
biden address this issue
absolutely oftentimes asian americans
struggle for visibility
we are are thinking ourselves does
anyone see us especially during this
time when we've seen these heightened
attacks against our community
to have the president speak out so
forcefully and denounce these attacks
against our community
gives us hope there's still a long road
ahead but at least we know that
someone sees us during this time
and what do you think is at the heart of
this mr yang
unfortunately there's a lot of things
going on and to be clear
we've seen this since back in january of
2020 when
covet 19 first hit our shores in the
united states
because of misinformation disinformation
people have this association that
somehow asian americans
are diseased or special carriers of
covet 19.
and unfortunately we've seen that before
in history where we've had the so-called
yellow peril back in the late 1800s
or other issues where asian americans
are seen as the perpetual foreigner
so certainly number one that is a driver
as to
why there there's this fear why there
are these attacks but the other thing we
need to remember is that
we are seeing a lot of economic
insecurity we
are seeing a lot of fear and whenever
people have fear
they look for someone to blame and
unfortunately in this case
the asian american community has become
a target
a question for you mr yang from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
john what if do you have any advice
if you are attacked or if perhaps you
see an attack like this going on what
should people do
sure and there's a lot of good things
that people can do and i appreciate that
question
first is it's important to report it
it's certainly
again it goes to this notion of
visibility that we've talked to
so our organization has a website called
stand against hatred dot org
where people could report hate incidents
so that we could document it we could
tell stories around it
the second thing i would encourage
people to consider is get what is called
bystander intervention training
so that allows a person if they see an
act of hate
and it doesn't have to be directed at
the asian american community but if they
see an act of hate or racism
they can do something about it now to be
clear i'm not asking people to be
superheroes and jump
in and stop something but there's
oftentimes little things that you can do
that makes that victim just feel a
little bit better and suffer a little
bit less trauma
in that moment
let me ask you this uh the role of
former president trump he continues to
refer to
covet 19 as the chinese virus he hasn't
been helpful has he
unfortunately he has absolutely not been
helpful and even just a few days ago
before president biden spoke
he referred to it again as the china
virus and certainly we know that anytime
language that is used like that it has
caused a spike in anti-asian racism
so it is clear that that is one of the
clauses the work the fact is that these
words matter
they matter to making people think about
cloven 19 in a certain way
to cause people to blame a certain
community for clove at 19.
and that i think president biden had it
right that has to stop
that's un-american
and do you see it stopping since his
speech last week
well unfortunately it's going to be a
long journey and number one is
we hope that as people become more aware
of this issue
people start to respond to it react to
it in a good way
but i think the other thing we have to
recognize is that this isn't going to go
away
anytime soon you know the reality is we
do have
geopolitical tensions with the chinese
government and those are real and those
are justifiable
but anytime you have these types of
world tensions there's
a need or a desire to blame a particular
community
and so even after covet 19 passes or is
under control
this is still an issue this issue of
racism that we all
must work on together
all right john yang of the group asian
americans advancing justice
thank you so much for being here tonight
thank you very much
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
and welcome back and now the winners and
losers in the media
and i'm joined by my colleague aiden
mclaughlin editor-in-chief of mediaite
with mediaites picks for the week this
week
we have both winners and losers from cnn
aiden so first let's go to the winners
let's hear what pamela brown had to
report this week on cnn
was he legitimately elected i saw him
inaugurated he was the president united
states
that's not the question is this really a
good standard to say oh well
you know back years ago they also used
russia to question legitimacy with
donald trump hillary clinton conceded he
was welcomed into the white house in
this case
you had someone saying the election was
stolen and millions of people believe
that line can you just say
that yes a majority of americans elected
joe biden into office
so she was a winner in your view aiden
tell us why
that's right so that's pamela brown
she's a senior washington correspondent
for cnn and she was recently named
anchor
of cnn saturday and sunday evening shows
and she's had a number of great moments
in recent months after being uh taking
over that show
particularly her interviews this sunday
was no different she interviewed michael
burgess
a texas congressman and a republican and
that's a very basic question
is joe biden the legitimate president
and was the 2020 election honest and
fair
uh now that of course has been a hard
question to answer
uh for a lot of republicans um because
of trump's delusions that he actually
won the 2020 election
um and his intolerance towards members
of his own party uh
that point out that he did not um
burgess dodged that question repeatedly
uh but brown did not let up
uh didn't even let him off the hook and
repeatedly ask the same question over
and over again
it ended up being a great interrogation
and a good example of how anchors should
handle politicians who lie on air about
what happened in the 2020 election
and it seems your pick for loser of the
week the mediaite loser of the week is
also cnn
so for their coverage of
governor andrew cuomo and listen to what
washington post media critic eric
whimple said on
a cnn broadcast this past weekend
chris cuomo the anchor at the nine
o'clock hour
who covered andrew cuomo and had all
these
wonderful loveathon interviews with him
more than 10 of them
and they suspended the conflict of
interest rule for chris cuomo for those
interviews
yet all of a sudden they've enforced it
again now that andrew cuomo was in the
midst
of an historic scandal in the albany
state house so i think
that is a major black eye for cnn
well that aired on cnn they they aired
the criticism right on their own network
what do you say about that aiden
right so that's eric wempel uh a very
tough uh media critic who writes for the
washington post and he was appearing on
reliable sources which is of course cnn
media show that airs on sunday um now
you know the very friendly interviews
that cnn anchor chris cuomo
held with his brother andrew cuomo have
come back to haunt uh cnn
in recent weeks uh given the scandals
swirling around the governor
um just to give you some background on
this cnn uh for years
banned chris cuomo from covering his
brother uh chris
cuomo has a prime time show on cnn that
airs at 9 00 pm
but then at the beginning of the
pandemic they lifted that ban
and allowed chris cuomo to interview his
brother for these sort of friendly
uh very uh chummy segments um he was on
uh nearly a dozen times at the beginning
of the pandemic and cnn
reinstated the ban after andrew cuomo's
handling of the pandemic became
controversial
um that's become even more of a black
eye for cnn as eric wempel noted
now that there are increasing
controversies turning around andrew
cuomo and calls on him to resign
in light of their handling of the
nursing home scandal and as well as
sexual harassment allegations against uh
the new york governor
um so that's become a problem for cnn
and uh the fact that it's being brought
up on their airwaves by a media critic
puts them in an uncomfortable position
with apologies we are out of time for
this week's episode so thank you
to our team at law and crime and thank
you to aiden
and uh we'll see you here next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you